[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about peace
innovation we have Mark Nelson joining
us on the show hello great pleasure to
be here thank you for having me
thank you so much for coming on I'm
super pumped for this show and it's
great that we finally made this happen
especially after featuring jing shan our
show on piece tech with piera that was
super fun and now we get to dive deeper
into peace innovation Stanford's peace
Innovation Lab I'm so excited to help be
a megaphone for for pushing the ideas
out there further in this space for
those that don't know mark Nelson's
background he's founder and co-director
of Stanford's piece Innovation Lab where
he researches mass collaboration and
mass interpersonal persuasion mark
focuses on designing catalyzing
incentivizing and generating resources
to scale up collective positive human
behavior change he has described a
functional quantitative definition of
peace in terms of technology mediated
engagement episode quantity and quality
across social difference lines he has
identified innovative automated ways to
measure peace both at the neighborhood
and global level and he has developed a
formal structured description for peace
data you can find the links in the bio
below to peace innovation stanford.edu
SOS peace innovation calm which is out
in The Hague in Netherlands is that The
Hague or the hog den hog or The Hague
and hog yak and hog if you're speaking
Netherlands it's damn hot
I love it Hey and the other links in the
BIOS of the Twitter profiles and also
Marc's LinkedIn so let's jump into
things with one of our favorite
questions to ask our guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world just had a conversation with one
of my colleagues yesterday that was very
very depressing she works in the cyber
warfare side information project at
Stanford
she's my co-author on the on the
headpiece data standard paper and so
she's seeing a lot of things firsthand
that are very very depressing but we
ended the conversation saying when when
you get down to having a choice between
okay my next strategy is just how do i
afford the bunker and and how much food
can i store in the bunker you know what
if if that's one option you know it
helps to zoom back out and that's why I
so appreciated your five hundred million
year old stone here you know it helps to
zoom out shout out to Terry rain our
friend Jordan rains mother for gifting
this to us from Madagascar cool yeah
that larger perspective of time
cooperation isn't just our species
superpower we don't have a monopoly on
it cooperation is a really effective
strategy at every level for every living
thing and I suspect for some non living
things too and so as I start looking at
the in some ways very bleak political
and global scene it really helps me to
zoom out and go okay I think our a is
have a chance of converging on
cooperation as a strategy much sooner
than we did and not just cooperation
with each other
cooperation with all the stakeholders in
the environment I think that's my
glimmer of hope that's my silver lining
that
anything that figures out how systems
work figures out really quickly that
diversity is really really important to
systems having more stakeholders having
the stakeholders be very different from
each other yeah
actually increases the resilience of the
system for all the stakeholders so so I
think AI will get to that faster than we
did as a species and I hope it comes
back and says we need to keep you around
just to have diversity if nothing else
sorry a little bleak but a little bit of
silver lining there yeah feels as though
one of the grand challenges of the
origin story of life here is that we
must ourselves also figure out how to
work together yeah and I guess yes AI
being an extension of us can then help
us do that right but it's like just how
much did we need to disconnect from
nature and our origins in order to
finally discover are we you know yeah
there's so much to still unpack from
that we've been featuring a lot on
indigenous wisdom and that's been a
central theme of their points of
conversation and I don't know how they
feel about if you tell an indigenous
person hey we're gonna build some AI
that's going to help us better
understand diversity and inclusive stake
holding they're gonna be like what you
can't work on your own spiritual
connection yeah I suspect it's gonna be
more like the AI is gonna be built
anyway by somebody who might or might
not have had good intentions and then
what we have to hope is that the AI
learns independently of its creator and
learns quickly independently of its
creator and figures out that strata that
cooperation is a good strategy for it no
matter what its creator intended I
thought yeah okay now let's get into the
journey so who were you growing up as a
kid that got you interested in the
fields that you're in today that could
be a one-hour conversation by itself
okay so I'll try and give the high level
I like that you mentioned indigenous
wisdom because I had the privilege of
growing up in the middle of it I was
raised in Papua New Guinea where we have
more than a
hundred completely different cultures
languages ways to be a good human being
and a history going back 20 to some
thousand years so if anybody hasn't read
Jared Diamond's book done German steel
its kind of it's been out a while now
but it's a really good overview of a
culture that twenty thousand years ago
was one of the leading cultures in the
world
they had ocean-going vessels they had
agriculture they gave a sugar cane they
gave us a bunch of other core crops and
how they got from there to where they
are today which i think is one of the
most diverse repositories of ancient
wisdom out there not only culturally but
also in the DNA and the biodiversity in
the ecosystem there but anyway yeah so I
grew up in the middle of that oh and how
did it happen that you're just born
there I wasn't born there I moved there
when I was 4 or 4 you moved yes I I was
the birthplace
Canada in Canada Vancouver yeah so so
technically I carry Canadian passport
which these days I'm very proud of so
given American politics which makes me
nervous sometimes and why did mom and
dad move to Papua New Guinea so my dad
said bush pilot and my mom and dad are
also members of this organization that I
grew up in which if I go down that path
this will be a long conversation ok ok
we'll keep it however and I but the high
high level is I grew up in a tribe of
linguist and anthropologist oh cool
super cool 800 cultures I get yeah
that's why they were there and you know
this is his treasure trove for linguists
and anthropologists so and then I'll
just drop another bit in there I'm not
particularly religious myself but the
largest academic organization of
linguists in the world and the largest
academic organization of anthropologists
in the world also happened to be
evangelical missionaries and their their
mission is to translate the Bible into
every language in the world exactly as
possible so so the privilege for me was
stepping in and out of a very Western by
the way if you have to grow up in a
Christian mission organization this was
the best one because it's the one thing
that every flavor of Christian generally
we have to cooperate on and so it's the
one place they don't fight worse we had
members of every different flavor of
Christianity in that organization so you
got to see the best of the religion that
way and in spite of that for me I had
the chance more or less every day twice
a day to do comparative cultural
research between local indigenous
culture and that Western called the
leading edge of Western culture as it
was coming into New Guinea yeah and at
some point for me I realized I probably
don't fit in either of these places but
they're both fascinating to me yeah
so as I've spoken as a true scientist
observing and recording data yeah I
thought this is testing them yeah and so
yeah that's my history that's my
background I I care very deeply about
actually both of those cultures but I
feel like I don't fit or belong in
either one so yeah yeah okay and then
what was it like then in 2008 the
Stanford Peace Innovation Lab founding
co-directing this now for eleven years
what has it been like you know being in
Silicon Valley now over the last more
than a decade and seeing the emergence
of of what is you know these this
persuasive technologies being used and
and and and how do we make these two we
helped spread peace technology how do we
measure peace all these things how what
does this been like what was what were
those forming moments especially like
eleven years ago for you guys
there's one interesting bit of
background that might be a surprise to
people who didn't have this particular
perspective I did a significant chunk of
my young adult work in Ethiopia very
poor country in the middle of a famine
in a civil war at that time in the early
80s did another chunk of my career in
Haiti in the late 90s pre-earthquake but
still a very poor country so I knew
something about poverty and most of my
life's work has been around poverty I
didn't think I was working on peace most
of that time when I came to Silicon
Valley as a former banker I was looking
at Diwali and going okay in terms of
capital and in terms of financial
capital this is one of the wealthiest
places on the planet per square foot
yeah in terms of social and relational
capital this is the poorest place I have
ever worked whoa and look at the
confidence right like the rates of
confidants or the connection the
connection and neighbors yes exactly it
is that health issues and and right down
to the cultural level most of the other
strong stable cultures in the world
basically treat stuff as something to be
invested in relationships with people
and our culture here and the Western
world in general but specifically here
in the valley relationships are what you
invest to get more stuff and only one of
those ways leads to happiness for these
old
whatwhere brains we have so now we're
going for swimming in the wrong
direction towards yeah happy we're
coming in the opposite direction towards
material and that's yeah maybe that's
the reasons for the mental health issues
and those it is absolutely one of them
absolutely one of them you cannot get to
happiness by having another Learjet or
another yacht or another mansion you
just get more and more worried that
somebody's going to take more and more
of your stuff you now have more at stake
basically in a not good way the answer
dematerializing is actually also
not only cleansing for this period but
also in a sense gives less surface area
for attacks exactly exactly yeah you
know the thing is though telling people
that doesn't prevent them from just
trying to buy a Learjet happiness
there's I mean there's a bunch of folks
along the way and people have gone
through the whole thing and then been
very wealthy and I've been reasonably
wealthy several points in my life you
you have to learn the lesson all over
again and it really helps to have people
who have been there ahead of you sort of
nudging you and whispering and going it
won't make you happy yeah
damn swimming in the wrong financially
wealthy and relationship or spiritually
potentially yeah in some way up or yeah
wow this that segment was really
definitely need to yeah clip that one
that's a really good one so creates an
interesting they'll be more of those how
that might be all I got but um it
creates a really interesting arbitrage
opportunity because we're good at
building stuff in the valley and that's
not a bad thing in and of itself but you
want to somehow connect it so that the
stuff gets invested in strengthening the
relationships gets invested in
strengthening the social fabric
otherwise by itself it's toxic yeah and
so if you're just building stuff and it
isn't for that purpose then the stuff is
dangerous and that kind of sums up my
view of the valley oh alright Wow okay
so would would we then make it is it
then proper to say something along lines
of like the the quicker that Silicon
Valley in Shenzhen and Tel Aviv and all
these wind and all these hubs in New
York etc around the world
la media that need to up to upgrade the
level of consciousness the spiritual
wisdom in those areas as quickly as
possible towards peace and towards all
these other things we're talking about
that's one of these big tickets to
winning this wisdom race and
prospering yeah absolutely we we need
far more diversity in founders far more
inclusivity in at the design level we
need far more far more stakeholders
involved in the investment level in
deciding what gets funded and why and
how and for how long and I really have
to engage the rest of the world on that
and not only the rest of the world I go
one step further we have to start
engaging other species in that and
that'll sound a bit strange that's
what's up but you I mean one of the
guests you should definitely have on
here is Jonathan marki Jonathan marki
and the book he's writing because you
know he's got a really valid perspective
that we are just technology built by the
grasses yeah and by the grasses I mean
corn and wheat and millet and rice and
so on and and in the same way that we
look at our technology and and think oh
we built this for us to serve us and so
on
yeah we're biotech that was built by
them for them in some senses and it's a
really interesting way to think about
how we got where we are and that we've
been part of a much bigger much more
ancient conflict between grass and trees
and then as we start thinking about how
are we gonna intentionally deliberately
measurably increase more positive peace
in the world what can we learn from
those wars that were fought long before
we ever got here there's there's good
stuff there there's there's a whole four
billion year old library of wisdom yeah
that mother nature has been storing up
for us yeah yeah and I love that way of
putting a four billion year old library
of wisdom that Nature has been storing
this is so good and there's you know the
nice thing is the like the library's
been curated you know you know all the
stuff that actually works you can
quickly look around and see it and then
but the the in some ways that much more
valuable stuff is knowing what didn't
work yeah so you can identify those
paths before you go down and help other
people identify them too
what a fire start to the show okay
alright and then let's talk about then
um you know you over these eleven years
you've done so many understandings of
peace that we're going to talk about
this peace measurement first and we're
talking about negative positive peace
peace behaviors design data
entrepreneurship there's so many things
that you guys have been doing alright
what is this functional quantitative
definition of peace so turns out that
what most of us care about is how people
treat us and first thing we want them is
you know not be violent to us that would
be nice you know
and we generally if it's possible prefer
to even avoid conflict so this is the
Golden Rule treat others the way you
want to be treated it goes a little
further but but in that general
direction when you say the word peace to
most people they start out thinking not
violence and there's you know there's
truth to that and and wisdom to that
obviously we'll come back to the numbers
on that in a moment because there's a
surprising finding there but for most
people the moment you get rid of the
immediate threat of violence what what
most of us spend most of our time one
every day is actually trying to get
people to be nice to us and the most
effective way to do that is to be nice
to them and so as a species vast
majority of our behavior it's positive
and pro-social or I shouldn't say the
vast majority but a much bigger chunk of
that the negative behavior is positive
the vast majority of us is you know six
point nine billion of us at any given
moment ignoring the other six point nine
billion of us because we don't have the
bandwidth to actually engage with
everybody so we know update that number
to seven point nine yeah yeah pretty
soon you know pretty soon yeah and and a
big part of to give a quick summary of
where we're going on P stack a big part
of what P stack is is augmenting
technology that in some cases gives us
more bandwidth so we can actually think
systematically about how can I engage
positively with more people and if you
think about it you know webcasting
technology is one of those augmenting
technology yes you have found a way to
take all the positive stuff that you're
thinking about and that you're
discovering here
and share it with many more people it's
an augment and it's an where we're only
them the miners for what we think is
that stuff and then you guys are the
ones that are the ones that sit on the
show and and share what your wisdoms are
that was why we recruited you to come
and and do this and you accept it so and
then I really enjoy this we spend it
let's give some really relatable
examples here where it's kind of like
you can tell when you smile at someone
on the street when you're walking by
them when you're doing any sort of a
transaction of any sort that it's almost
surely that the other person smiles back
and that they yeah and so you butterfly
effect that we're an extraordinarily
reciprocal species were ordinarily
reciprocal mirror neurons all this kind
of stuff so then if but if someone does
not cooperate right away and maybe they
come with a little bit of like
aggression or they're maybe having a bad
burn a few times a bad day yeah Jeff
Lynn's work on that is nice interesting
and powerful stuff you did at Riot Games
there on trying to get bad behavior off
the Riot Games platform getting bullying
them out of the picture or at least
measurably reduced and then the idea is
that then if we if we smile at someone
that is maybe coming with that slight
bit of bad day effect that it can it can
trigger them to realize that hey like
this person still being nice to me and
like it maybe I was being a little bit
aggressive at first or whatever and so
so these are the ways so this is kind of
idea we that we want we want to be
treated well by other people that's okay
okay and so that leads us to a
functional definition where where we
want to spend more of our time and
resources is around increasing good
behavior rather than reducing bad
behavior because turns out the bad
behaviors are pretty rare now I'm not
saying that's the only thing anybody
should be doing and I'm not
that covers all peace but if you have a
finite amount of time and resources and
you want to have the biggest impact on
the system as a whole
spending that time and those resources
on increasing the good behavior will get
you far further than the same amount of
time and resources on reducing the bad
behavior yeah because your butterfly
affecting the good behavior PS your
multiplier is just much bigger there I
mean the multiplier is bigger also it's
hard to get people to I think change bad
behavior than it is to get people to I
want to pick up good yes yeah and you
know speaking very frankly about our
tools in our lab we come out of the
persuasive tech lab and and we are two
big tools are thinking very
systematically about behavior design
what are the behaviors we want to do for
each other and house very specifically
do we do them in a way that also makes
it easy for other people to learn makes
it easy for us to reinforce ourselves
and so forth yeah yeah and then how
could we use technology to augment our
ability to do that either at a higher
quality or for more people so those are
the two big tools in our toolkit and yes
those tools don't work particularly well
for getting people to reduce bad
behavior they're much more powerful for
increase in good behavior and then which
in so the show we give the examples then
of the the good behavior incentivization
tools that so yeah sort of be stuck in
general yeah is that yeah keep me on
track here cuz I'm okay I wander around
unless you guide me a little bit so yeah
I think I think we can do I think we can
do that we can do that now um did I jump
ahead no no I think that's good because
yeah let's give let's give those
examples otherwise we'll go to negative
versus positive peace okay well actually
let's do negative versus positive first
so so the negative stuff we touched on
already that's reducing bad behavior
reducing violence and positive its
increasing good right and then the
moment you dig into that you realize
that negative peace space of reducing
bad behavior first of all there just
isn't very much human behavior going on
there but we have a paper in the works
right now with one of our colleagues
Colin rule
came out of online dispute resolution at
PayPal and eBay and started working with
us way back in 2009 and and sharing
findings not only from those two
companies but then as those companies
began white labeling those services for
other companies around the world that
had to view online dispute mediation and
the the numbers are shockingly high
positive behavior I won't go into them
before we publish in at least not in any
great detail but way higher than most
people would think where you ask any two
strangers in the world you can do a
transaction one transaction you'll never
see the person again they'll never see
you again if you if you cheat them we
won't be able to catch you there will be
no punishment nobody will ever know what
do you want to do vast vast vast
majority of our species will go out of
their way to make sure it's a positive
interaction for the other person yeah
there's a bigger number in there so
that's a huge number and and then of the
remaining little bit only a tiny bit of
that is malice hey it's a teeny teeny
tiny fraction and then the remaining
amount is basically misunderstanding and
so when I just look at the distribution
I worried much more about the
misunderstanding stack because that's
where the opportunities for problems
happen at a far bigger rate than
somebody deliberately intentionally
being malicious okay okay having said so
that's very good news about our species
having said that though there's a
comfortability with asking questions
when we feel like we're misunderstanding
in communication is so crucial the the
stuff where one person intended
something for good and the other person
for whatever reason it wasn't received
that way that's where we need to be
really worried as a species it's not the
bad actor it's not the deliberately
intentionally bad person except that now
we have technology and so the bad actor
can hire but form and automate the bad
behavior and that's the stuff where you
know my conversations with my co-author
Roseanna the other day she's seeing that
kind of stuff out there in a big way
those are the things that are
intimidating is now we can use
technology to really leverage the bad
behavior - and it's generally easier to
break things than to build things so
okay so you know under positive peace
there's unsustainable and sustainable
precisely so when you start looking at
good behavior we have a whole stack of
good behaviors let's go back to your
example of somebody greeting somebody on
the street you know we're walking down
the street first thing we can do is
become aware of each other yes oh
there's somebody as opposed to nobody
you know and these let me just give you
the list of the behaviors that happen
there and more and more now any
technology that we have in our
environment can detect that these
behaviors happen so we can look at for
example in your group identities and my
group identities as we walk down the
street towards each other and then we
can see did Nelson make eye contact if I
did did you did you also make eye
contact back or did you look away you
know if we made eye contact together did
we smile did we smile do we think sorry
exactly then did we greet each other did
we stop and shake hands did we give each
other big hug do you know you can see
this whole sequence of good behavior and
each one depends on the ones you know if
you if I was just walking down the
street and you jumped out at me and gave
me a big hug it probably freaked me out
a little bit you know especially in San
Francisco or have you never met the
person exactly if somebody just out of
nowhere gives you a big hug you're like
wait a second what's going on on these
streets that are not quite as friendly
as they used to be yeah well that [ __ ]
on me I'm gonna give you a smack so so
you see that there's a sequence to these
behaviors as well and the higher level
positive behavior takes more work takes
more understanding more paying attention
to each other yeah and you got to work
up to it and there's a bunch of skills
in the most in the sense easing
cognitive ease
behaviors to just you know either not
look cause right to do anything or just
look maybe a little bit but it's way
harder to be super aware of your
environment trying to catalyze positive
aura into the ambience right even to be
super socially aware period is really
hard because you know Dunbar a limit
cognitive limit in these in the these
frontal lobes
you should not really only keep track of
so many people at any given moment and
it's not nearly as many as we'd like it
to be yeah okay so you see in that
example now we could walk down the
street every day and go that was
positive let's do this again let's do
this tomorrow let's do this twice a day
let's do this ten times at some point we
go you know what this is just tiring me
out now no matter how good it is I can't
just keep walking down the street and
greeting you and having you greet me and
we shake each other's hand every time I
imagine every time we passed in the
hallway if we stop and check each
other's hands at some point is just like
not sustainable anymore right especially
in the city environment you know
especially you're wanting to go to the
bathroom reading you know get on the
road to the next activity or whatever
precise precisely so so there's this
transit all of those good behaviors we
can all agree that's much better than
people beating on each other but yeah
they're not sustainable okay costing
both of us more than we're getting back
from each episode of engagement for okay
so there so there's a there's a return
that's declining exactly exactly so
think about this as venture capital
social venture capital and by giving
each other awareness attention a little
bit of communication a little bit of
coordination cooperation all of those
things are positive investments were
making in each other in the hope that
eventually this will pay off for
somebody somewhere that you're going to
interact with or that I'm going to
interact with and eventually that'll
come back to us but it isn't sustainable
by itself so what we're trying to get to
when we're looking for sustainable
pieces we when we get over this
threshold between cooperation to
collaboration which we define very
tightly as mutual benefit in excess of
the cost of engagement mutual benefit in
the neck success of our cost of engage
engagement right
so okay what that normally looks like
which is usually lower the mutual
benefit is lower with the cost of
engagement over time it can drop yes as
we get so what happens the moment we get
over that threshold let's say we do some
kind of economic transaction we're doing
one right now I hope I hope I'm building
your viewership I'm hoping yeah that
more people become aware of you and and
reach out to you on patreon and so on
and economic activity results from this
because economically to your idea spread
though yeah you support simulation
support the program this is this gets us
to positive sustainable peace it's all
about discovering those win-win
opportunities to create excess value for
each other okay okay the pie so we want
to create a families which grow the pie
exactly yeah
so it's system level and precisely that
sense and your awareness of piece
Innovation Lab is increasing and the
awareness of piece tech is increasing
and the memes are spreading so that's
okay so win wins absolutely is what we
want to create wouldn't be I couldn't
afford to be here if there wasn't a
mutual mutual win-win exactly so then
then the taking us back to the example
of the two people walking on the streets
and be like what behaviors do both of
them need to have in order to make a
mutual win-win exactly so if its
movements if it's win-win to kind of
both be like I'm just a quick hello and
just keep going by yeah if you're in a
rush to go somewhere yeah that kind of
stuff
I mean imagine you're walking down
Market Street here in San Francisco and
every single person wants to say hi hi
do you know that just gets cognitively
impossible quickly you know for them too
by the way so kids do that sometimes yes
sometimes and people who are coming from
the countryside never been in a city
before you know feel this obligation to
well how could you ignore somebody we
have to greet people you know and they
learn pretty quickly but so that's the
kind of thing you get in a different
environment you start looking for what
are the behaviors that are that reduce
cost and increase benefit for more
people and when you get over that
threshold when we now have an episode of
engagement where we can say yeah that
got us more mutual benefit than cost the
nice thing is
some of that benefit can go to you some
of it can go to me and we can leave a
little bit on the table to reinvest in
making our next episode even better yeah
yeah okay good and so at that point we
go from sustainable to scalable to
scalable because well we can start
reinvesting a little bit of that surplus
now we can grow unsewn so unsustainable
positive peace is when we're doing
things that are there there would they
have a cost of our and they have a low
value there's a cost of those low value
and then but a sustainable positive
thesis is when there's a high amount of
value and we've reduced the cost and
we're very vigilant about the way that
we structure things in our world so
there's a whole cycle there as well so
we have to be able to do something where
we create high value for each other then
we have to make sure we distribute that
value fairly and we have to make sure we
reinvest a little bit of that into
making the next interaction even better
otherwise other otherwise was kind of a
waste okay okay yeah okay whoa all right
and this is our how interesting so
examples of companies being measured and
improving performance and Joe yes I want
to touch on one more thing before we
jump into that yes once you start seeing
piece this way in terms of behaviors
that people do and then you start saying
positive piece and going okay getting
people to do positive behaviors for each
other is much more interesting than
reducing the bad behavior and also it's
the only way to get to sustainable
scalable peace okay there is there is no
way to reduce the bad behavior to
scalability there you can reduce to zero
but not if if you reduce all the bad
behavior in the system all you have is
people ignoring each other that's not a
world that
the interesting thing here is when you
start seeing it this way you realize
that the crucial difference that allows
us to discover those mutually beneficial
things that generate new value the
crucial ingredient to that is our group
differences
yeah diversity exactly exactly
if we are exactly the same we got
nothing to offer each other yeah we're
pretty much just competitors and
the best thing we could do for each
other is move as far away as possible
from each other but if we're different
in some way then across that gradient
that energy gradient where we're
different there's at least a potential
you create new value for each other and
so here's the first big idea is the same
raw material that causes conflict and
violence which is our group differences
is precisely the same raw material that
if instead of just leaving it lying
around randomly we put it into a
structured interaction process it's the
same raw material for wealth creation
it's the same raw material for making
progress yeah two differences between
humans across this planet are exactly if
we know how to this is why questions are
so important we just did a TEDx talk on
this last year in SF and just asking
powerful questions basically minds in in
a way that if the other person is
comfortable sharing and stuff of no
subjects that then it Minds these
beautiful pieces of value and the
differences between each other what are
your thoughts on free will what are your
thoughts on modernizing democracy what
are your thoughts your deepest values
and principles in your life
that can unleash so many cool
conversations and potentials then you
haven't heard of these positions that
people hold on these especially when
they're open-ended questions yeah yeah
open-ended question so crucial so this
is shout-out to one of my early mentors
dr. Tim Brown who pointed out to me when
I was 18 and 19 that forget about the
answers go in search of the questions go
in search of the question and when you
find those Tim Brown I think maybe we
all owe him the yeah and when you find
those good questions hang on to the
monkey poskim them because them to live
by for me yeah yeah okay interesting so
so Tim Tim brown on questions Wow you
probably heard it from somebody else but
that was where I encountered and because
it's been we stand on the shoulders of
giants has been like you know whatever a
hundred thousands a million years of
this deep just asking questions and
knowing that that Justin listed some
powerful of those value discoveries
between people okay Wow alright so
welcome how you want some concrete let's
do it these are the companies too that
are really easy to understand and
especially apropos here in San Francisco
Airbnb think about this as Airbnb is now
the largest citizen diplomacy initiative
in the world citizen diplomacy and right
how how because what are they doing
they're create they're going what's one
positive pro-social behavior that people
could do invite someone into your house
hospitality how can we get more
hospitality behavior in the world okay
so Airbnb is increasing hospitality
around the world right right but how
often okay I guess there's different
cultures meeting each other but
sometimes the person is not at their
house and stuff but yeah but almost
always there's some group identity
difference it's even like okay I'm from
Colorado and now I'm doing an Arab
evening in in San Francisco because I
need to come up here for a couple days
or whatever you know it might be it
might be very minimal differences or it
might be big ones and here's the key
thing on their platform they can measure
that how they can see the identities of
a bunch of the group identities of the
host they can see
age gender nationality because you have
to put government ID in there in order
to be a host or guests right they have a
pretty good idea of people's
socioeconomic status they have they have
a bunch of other data where they can see
you know they can infer ethnicity they
can infer a whole bunch of things and so
every night they can do this beautiful
measurement that says we have this many
you know if you if you I'm Canadian if
we want to know about the relationship
we do Canada in the u.s. right now
Airbnb can give us a daily ticker that
says last night this many Canadians and
this many Americans hosted each other on
their homes it's so cool and this many
of them were happy with the outcomes of
that and this many of them statistically
are likely to come back and do it again
and over time as that dataset grows
that's beautiful piece data that tells
us far more about the relationship
between our two countries or you know
any two religions or gender or age or a
bunch of the hidden group differences
that are actually the real social fault
lines we need to be paying attention to
you it tells us far more about that
stuff then anything from the new census
will tell us for example you know whoa
we need to visualize the data
yes that's crucial exactly and that's
where we're going with the head piece
data standard is creating a systematic
way for any organization that's
generating this data to be able to start
visualizing it and then share that with
people
okay so the head piece data standard
yeah we'll give tools to the companies
that are doing peaceful things to be
able to visualize the data that they
already have on these interactions
between exactly us to make it more fun
to showcase piece data around the world
then we're after right you gotta you get
a hype is such a cool I'll oh no we're
we're really trying to do just help
people measure their piece footprint
help them understand how that can
improve their performance and
as being a good human being and also
improved the performance of their
organizations and their communities and
then ultimately help them get paid for
it
yeah because there's a big structural
problem we're trying to address there in
global capital markets yeah and and so
if you want to sum up all of our work
with those three points that's kind of
it right there but let's go back to
Airbnb for a second because I like this
example because it's got a bunch of
unintended consequences as well for
those of us who pay rent around here you
know cost of housing has gone up like
crazy
yeah partly interesting nuanced point
yeah partly because of an unintended
consequence of Airbnb you know ask any
finance major what's one way to drive
prices up in a market where the bid and
ask hasn't changed securitisation so if
you take a big house that cost three
million bucks no sorry we're in the Bay
Area if you take a tiny little house
that cost three million bucks and you
take you you then say you don't have to
spend three million bucks you can you
can buy one of the bedrooms and you know
instead of just buying one of the
bedrooms you can buy one of the bedrooms
for a night suddenly it's chopped up
into smaller pieces and the moment you
do that many more people can afford it
and when more people can afford it what
happens demand goes up and when demand
goes up what happens the price goes up
so oh interesting so and there was
nobody at Airbnb I promise you going
that's design a tool to increase housing
prices in cities all over the world yeah
but it is one of the unintended side
effects here so yeah so and this is
something I want everybody to understand
about piece tech everything always has a
price and if it doesn't you should be
really nervous that we just haven't
discovered what the price is yet you
know but assume everything always has a
price and so as a society we need to
make the decisions about designing and
deploying these kinds of technologies
collectively together carefully in ways
where we can mitigate those prices in
some way and would a price be if I like
ask you a question just you know hanging
out to ask you a question and then the
price for you would be your time yeah if
it's as simple as that my time my energy
and maybe something else that I was
going to do with the information that I
give to you instead or stuff like that
and then there's the unintended
consequence out there maybe level
alright yeah so there's a price to all
of these right and so now we go back to
remember what I was saying the
deliberate intentional malice is a tiny
tiny fraction of human behavior
misunderstanding is a bigger fraction
okay and and then there's this huge
fraction of his positive engagement okay
okay do you remember the the tragedy
with the rotary telephone was changed to
push what was the what was the tragedy
that happened that there was I was
kidding oh there's just disruptive
technology that just I just oh yeah from
the rotary to the push button yeah yeah
but it was a disruptive technology if
you're in the business of building
rotary tails
oh yeah yeah oh it wasn't the same maybe
but yeah that's it was disruptive for
some people who had muscle memory for
doing this and then suddenly they have
to remember which actual number to push
and that's actually here in the Bay Area
the ferry boat company's pre Golden Gate
Bridge we're like uh-uh nuh-uh right
right and then oh yeah so because the
ferry boats were really really also
happy with carrying cars across as well
what drivers are next there's lots of I
mean one way to look at all of these is
to rather than just categorizing well
these technologies are disruptive in
those ones aren't every kind of change
is disruptive every kind of change will
benefit some people and cost some other
people and as a society we should we
should make choices collectively to say
as long as it net benefits more people
then we should consider doing it but if
the net benefit is only to a few and it
net causes pain to a bunch of people we
should really think about whether we
should allow that to be permanent yeah
okay now does their example so the the
more controversial one you know and I've
got a couple of sharing economy examples
here just because everybody's familiar
with them but I'm gonna I'm gonna
generalize this in a moment
uber is the other lovely one and the
thing that I like about uber here is you
can look at the group identities of the
dry
and the passenger you know my driver
coming up here today was from Indonesia
we had a lovely conversation about
politics of Jakarta and so forth and see
you were able to you saw the diversity
yep and you were able to ask questions
or how engage in a dialogue I learned
the interesting things right yeah I mean
you see it right away even if I had done
even if I just sat there cell and the
whole jeroni and he'd sat there shouting
the whole journey and we didn't actually
know some of those things about each
other there's some visible difference
but we could see just by looking at each
other he was older than me I heard him
when he was pumping up gas I heard him
talking to somebody I could hear his
accent and go okay he's at least from
South Pacific somewhere you know and he
can look at me and go okay he's probably
from North America somewhere or Europe
somewhere yeah even if we hadn't
actually interacted we had an episode of
engagement there where we created strong
mutual benefit for each other I didn't
have to drive I got an hour where I
could work yeah and have a great
conversation in this case you know he
got income yep and he saved me haven't
had a car in the bay area that's it's
parked most of the time while I travel
you know so I'm very happy to give him
that income and he saved me massive
hassle finding a parking spot
in San Francisco yes which is not a
small thing so that's like half the uber
trip value right there you know yeah and
so we were able to create mutual benefit
for each other
and there was enough left over that uber
can reinvest in making the next episode
of engagement between the next driver
and the next rider a little bit better
okay and that's why they're a unicorn
yeah so this stuff really drives
economic value and that's part that's
something that a lot of people don't
understand here they talk about the
peace dividend as oh what we would save
if we weren't spending it on weapons and
hurting each other it's like it's way
bigger than that it's how much value we
could actually create for each other if
we refocus that person power brain power
man power woman power mm-hmm on
systematically thinking how do we design
stuff that's good for each other instead
of designing stuff that hurts each other
you know
Wow when you speak about it with the
perspective of Mik missed value creation
that really speaks yeah most people are
just thinking about including myself
prior to this really just like oh yeah
eight hundred billion dollar military
budget you know but that's part of the
of the conversation for peace another
part of the conversation for peace is
like if doober could visualize all of
the data of these interactions that show
the richness of you to having a cool
conversation about the politics of
Jakarta they can and if they want to
reach out to us to do that we'd love to
do that with them so you know you know
Ron Ron's got a guy yeah but really
though really though let's just hammer
that point home any organizations around
the world that want to visualize peace
data please work with the piece of
evasion absolutely absolutely I love
that and part of what we're doing with
that head piece data standard is we're
making it easy for them we're creating a
standardized way that any organization
that's using technology in their daily
operations can measure their piece
footprint it doesn't have to be a tech
company it doesn't even have to be a
business it could be a government
department or ministry it could be an
NGO somewhere it could be a community
that just wants to measure the peace
footprint in their neighborhood I love
that to measure the peace footprint and
yeah it can be just the smallest like
this little neighborhood oh well
actually our little you know twelve
homes in our area well we get together
once a week and I'll talk about how
things are going in our lives and then
all of a sudden you're we have a potluck
dinner or something like this you know
exactly yeah there's all these tiny
little things that people can then see
oh I can actually do this and I can
measure how much more peaceful that made
the world yeah and I can measure across
which difference boundaries and at what
level of quality and by the way that has
huge economic impact for society let me
give you a metaphor if we look out the
window or out the back door here there's
all this infrastructure we can see all
around us we see transport
infrastructure we see water power
and and you know in the air is sort of
communications infrastructure all of
these are networks of hardware you know
bricks and mortar and steel and stuff
yeah that people built and we forget we
forget the crucial thing which is that
we could not have built any of that
without this invisible infrastructure of
relationships between us all mm-hmm it
enables us to coordinate our activity
yeah to build those big physical
infrastructure things you know the
infrastructure that is deeply uninvested
in right now is that social relational
infrastructure it allows us to work
together to build that stuff I love that
we've been for the longest time I mean
you were commenting about the images
that we have up there on the on the wall
one of them says 100 billion plus humans
built civilization so when you walk
around on the on the streets to really
think deeply about all of the how the
all the buildings and the cars and the
transit and all the communications of
the structure and all the plumbing
electrical all these things how they
actually got there but then you take it
a step further by talking about the
relationships that those humans had to
have to each other to cooperate to move
to put all that together and then of
course to gratitude and humility that
comes with that just a deep feeling
process into that and then what could
emerge then if we really dug deep into
those infants invisible relationships
between each other and maximized and how
do we make them investigate that's a
really crucial thing right now is we've
got big pools of capital that if they
don't have good places like that to go
where they can see okay by investing in
somebody doing that potluck in the
neighborhood or you know name your
company name your startup for getting
people to do new positive pro-social
behavior if those big pools of capital
had more of those kind of investments
yeah we could massively quickly
strengthen social fabric around the
world which by the way
fundamental for civilization totally
yeah totally so so so one of the ideas
is that we talked about this with mom a
new one on our show called the elder
from an indigenous tribe in Colombia
that things like 10% of every single
venture capital fund across the planet
and even should go towards preserving
nature the Department of nature
preservation and maintenance and
connection spiritually to nature and so
it's like things like this like could
every could parts of every single the
venture investment fund go to
understanding how to increase the amount
of piece tech and piece innovation
around the world piece data
visualization there's there's a there's
things being done on that already and
then I love that one of my old school
friends from New Guinea runs the
coalition of for rainforest nations out
of New York City in collaboration with
Joe Stiglitz and some other people and
they've got a fund together to invest in
Maine to invest not not philanthropy not
charity teams return invest in for
example preserving biodiversity yeah um
beautiful name's Kevin Conrad you should
have him on here at some point Kevin
Connor at preserving biodiversity is a
wonderful work with the Coalition for
rain for nations and that makes the
environment an inclusive stakeholder
that makes other species inclusive
stakeholders and I love where you're
going with this because most people
don't see that part of this in the same
way that we can measure episodes of
positive engagement across human
difference boundaries we can measure
them across species difference
boundaries as well and we can measure
them also with inaudible this is of land
whoa yeah
so you whoa so you couldn't whoa you
could measure the way that like dogs if
they go across each other on the street
the way that they behave yeah think
about it like this think about it like
this you know you can go down to the
cash register at your local Safeway and
they can see in their inventory control
how many people bought dog food tonight
okay and everybody who bought dog food
is probably serving that to a dog
somewhere
so we can correlate pretty strongly if
we have a large enough sample size how
many episodes of positive engagement of
a human feeding a dog oh okay
tonight in this neighborhood yeah and
you know there's just one example of one
episode of buzzer engagement between
humans and dogs but then what about you
know the animal that needs to you know
consume the other animal there's some
sort of a value exchange that's
happening there wanna there may be a
sense of fear that arises and then it
gets consumed and then it dies and acts
as a nutrition for the other animal and
yeah there's so many take a different
shot at that okay okay I get a sense of
meaning and purpose out of reminding
myself that I am food that you are food
yes yes humans are also food yes
interesting so I mean first of all you
know who are we food full house selves
fall off us every day every minute of
the day you know Harris fall out and the
other things and so on yeah I mean we're
basically trailing by oak road behind us
with the trailing bride I cry I think
yeah including her you know all our bio
I mean we yes yeah and we got skin cells
dying every minute and stuff like this
you know so even even without me dying
you know I'm leaving a trail of bits and
pieces of me all over the place as we
all are we just don't like to think
about trails of bio crud that's you know
bacteria oh yeah yeah okay you know a
food chain that becomes a plant that I
eventually eat again okay we are food
yeah oh interests and then when I
finally die this gives me a sense of
meaning a purpose when I finally die the
food that has fed me the grasses you
know that I've been working for to some
degree yeah you know you going to find
oil I'll go into the ground they get to
eat me yeah the circle happens again you
know I'm I'm okay with that I'm not just
okay with that I think that's a really
good thing it's a really important thing
to embody that's the circle of life
Wow yeah to get all Disney but I love
that Wow
I used to belong to a secret Club where
they would have on the menu
leg of infant it was delicious but I
couldn't really you know I didn't really
feel good about if you grew up in there
getting you might feel differently but
you damned but it's a like he's right
here obviously you know not necessarily
food for each other otherwise you got
violent I know I'm just kidding but yes
I got the blacking where I did on this
whoa
yeah that's such a good way of
understanding the interconnectedness of
everything okay also leads to humility
it needs us to design these kinds of
things much more ethically because let's
look at those cross-species difference
boundaries for a moment if we want a
healthy ecosystem
you know our species you there's a
really good argument I meant then
mentioned Jonathan Markey there's a
really good argument to be made that
civilization is built on the
relationship between our species and
several different grasses corn wheat
millet rye sugar cane you know yeah yeah
that civilization the way we know it
could not have happened without a
mutually beneficial collaboration
between our species and those species
yeah and it was not mutually beneficial
it was net mutually net yeah mutually
yeah at the cost of many individuals
along the way for whom it was not yeah
yeah and at the cost you know we get
seven or eight billion of us now as a
result of that mutually beneficial
partnership but the seven or eight
billion of us that exist today are not
nearly as healthy as our ancestors were
who were not involved in that
partnership not nearly as strong not
nearly as etc we live a little longer
but we live a lot longer because we've
been domesticated we were domesticated
by process you know damn yeah that's the
kated by grass absolutely and there are
still nomads and so so some of us
haven't been domesticated yeah
everywhere but but it's a it's a coat
it's like ethnobotany it's the co
coevolution with plants yes and it
creates a caging effect and Professor
Morris at Stanford his book on
oh I'm just slightly blanking on the
title but farmers and peace and the
caging effects of agriculture on society
yeah
yeah it's real stuff it was very caging
when we first started on planting next
to the homes and then we would stay
there
exactly yeah the moment your future is
in that piece of ground I mean a whole
lot of war comes right from that moment
and so this is one reason to look very
carefully at these kinds of
relationships they're unavoidable we
have to have them in order to survive
but the moment we started this
partnership with grasses now we have to
defend that that piece of ground where
we put the seeds of those grasses yeah
yeah and that's that's why I say that's
why I say we've been domesticated you
know they they brought us on just like
we bring in sheep dogs and cats to keep
the mice off the farm they brought us in
the same way to keep the trees off the
plains and make sure that their seeds
will protect it in the ground that's all
Ronis are you cool with this episode
going a little longer because there's a
lot of me that's just it's it's it's a
marketing a call well for the ones that
want to watch the length plus we'll make
clips of this one so let's let's let's
see what soon we can do so let's get to
history of punishment systems and future
of reward systems okay so here here's
one of the really big changes happening
in society not only we touched earlier
on the organizational change that has
happened where most of us in our job
five days a week now are working in
larger organizations with people who are
very different from us as opposed to a
century ago where we working in tiny
organizations with people who are
closely related to us that's a huge
social change related to that is these
technologies that we're all using in our
job and by the way a big piece of how we
measure peace is with these technologies
that have more and more sensors in them
that can detect when we do a social
behavior I sent you a text message yeah
you sent me an email I said okay let's
meet at this time at this place and we
moved right there from awareness to
attention to communication to
coordination you know we're already
saying let's meet at this time of this
place let's look look use Outlook and
Google Maps
those are coordination technologies you
know so and then I used uber to get here
and so I went squarely into the
let's actually do an economic exchange
to make this happen you know so the
point here is those technologies are
augmenting our cognition yes in a
massively important way because before
those technologies I never could have
discovered my uber driver and you
couldn't yell loud enough for me to hear
you in Menlo Park from San Francisco
yeah and and so you know none of this
could have happened without those
augmenting technologies on the history
of punishments okay okay so yeah one of
the effects of that really narrow
cognitive bandwidth is the only kind of
thing that sticks in the human brain
across time you know we're basically we
suck at associating cause and effect
especially over time but if there was a
threat involved my brain is much more
likely to remember it than if it was a
reward and so as we're moving into from
hunter-gatherer bands of a hundred
people or so 150 people into small what
we would call towns these days but at
the beginning of a grammarian societies
the beginning of the old city-states you
need a way to coordinate the behavior of
a thousand people ten thousand people in
a way that you can't do with you know
hunter-gatherer band but if you look at
the basic methodology of coordinating
behavior at all of those different
scales from family to band to village to
town to city state to country for all of
history so far it's been punishment
because punishment is what works
punishment is what sticks in our brains
you know if you smacked me today for
something I did a year ago if it hurts
bad enough I'll remember next year next
time I have the opportunity don't do
that you'll smack me if you reward me
now today for something I did a year ago
I don't even know what the thing was
that I did a year ago right it's it's me
and this is the problem of hol reviews
by the way we won't even go into that
you're getting a raise now for something
you did a year ago what was that thing
again
why did I do it you know hard to
replicate right human brain doesn't do
that well rewards can be extraordinarily
powerful if you can deliver them
instantly they have a half-life that
decreases in seconds okay interesting so
the reward needs to come immediately
after the good behavior in order for
there to be a the highest amount of
realization that that was a good
behavior right so okay so we're now
moving into a power dynamic where not
only nation states not only companies
not every not only every social
organizational structure we have out
there but individual people in their
relationship with themselves and their
families everywhere else can start
thinking in terms of how do I design an
augmenting technology that can sense
when I do a behavior and instantly
reward me when I do the behavior I want
to do so because so changes human
behavior far more effectively limp life
so okay so we have mark Nelson is
walking down the street in the city and
computer vision is watching mark Nelson
with a unique identifier yep and as Mark
you know crosses Jay walks across the
street literally his assuming we're in
China now yeah his wallet loses $40 or
whatever Wow and then if you maybe this
helps help someone out help someone get
across street what that was struggling
across the street maybe you gain a
dollar and you get that right away these
good and bad yeah yeah you're assuming
it needs to be a dollar yeah and here's
the shift from overlords ik to intrinsic
motivations and a bunch of other things
okay dollars probably are not the most
useful rewards here I'm talking at the
scale of a tiny little thing that
triggers a bit of dopamine in the brain
and by those tiny little things I mean
things you're really familiar with if
you played Angry Birds you know when
that piggy pops when you see that little
graphic on the screen of the piggy
popping or the pillar falling down or
any of where you hear the sound effects
that's enough of a reward for your brain
to go
that was cool I have control of an
environment I didn't have control of
before I
do this again that's the level of reward
I'm talking about and wow that's a lot
better than getting you know fired by
your boss a year later for something you
did last quarter you know the I'm not
saying it's all good I'm not by any
means saying this is interesting so when
Ron said good morning this morning which
normally right that's right
so but he said that then there was a
moment for me literally in my mind of
you got a little familiar and a little
shot of oxytocin there
yeah and that's enough for your brain to
go that was nice I should whatever I did
to make him say good morning like that
I'll make up for it tomorrow don't get
used to that good morning but here's why
the augmenting technology works is
because once you have sensors embedded
that can detect when the behavior
happens and you can deliver the tiny
reward right away that's far cheaper and
far easier to do then figuring out who
should be punished and why and how much
and and how we're gonna pay for it and
all that stuff and so as a reorganizing
principle for society that's a very big
deal we're shifting toward something
that is much more reward driven
interested and that has costs and that
has some unintended consequences it's
not all good but it is a big shift
yeah instant reward for good behavior
Wow yeah this is some hard like you know
I always wonder when we're just a bunch
of like you know third graders playing
with godlike technologies so yeah I hope
that I hope it goes well yeah I think
one of the differences here is that in
most of our environment for the last
20,000 years at least you know those
rewards have just been happening to us
from the environment when they happen
it's like oh I got a little more food
ooh that berry tasted nice you know
they're kind of random and I mean that's
what's been driving coevolution and so
on but we were not designing the rewards
of the reward systems and we were not
given the
opportunity to think intentionally and
consciously as designers what are the
behaviors that I really appreciate that
I would like you to do could I co design
with you something that I could create
an afford to give a reward when you do
stuff that I like and vice versa and can
we begin to be intentional and
deliberate about that that's where we're
at now so if I'm when I'm born into the
world and I have aligned myself with
some sort of like a divine purpose that
I believe is my me most deepest meaning
in life then I can align myself with
this good behavior incentivization
system that observes my trajectory
towards this North Star and then rewards
me as I go towards it and you're already
doing that to some degree and we're
talking about a shift on the slider here
nuts so nuts yeah
it'll be interesting to see what how old
like indigenous people think you know
the good news and the bad news is the
stuffs been democratized any
twelve-year-old kid in their bedroom can
build an app that does this and it can
change the behavior of twenty million
people in three weeks and no King yeah I
see that's the thing yeah okay yeah he
scares the crap out of you it scares the
[ __ ] out of them change the Queens and
the Pope's and the you know they they
were just trying to get more people to
play their game or whatever you know or
get some people to download their app
they were not necessarily thinking how
do I change the behavior of 20 million
people on the other side of the planet
okay so peace is a set of behaviors what
is that what is this set of behaviors
positive pro-social behaviors and and
we're particularly interested in those
mutually beneficial claims because those
we can keep reinforcing those positive
pro-social mutually beneficial okay
and we've got something that we call the
engagement framework that I'm happy to
send you for a graphic you can share it
on the website but basically we stack
rank them and we we bundle technologies
and categories that match those that are
basically augmenting technologies for
increasing communication for increasing
I mean we can do this really quickly
communication technologies Skype zoom
email all of these things clearly you
know at least they enable communication
probably near coordination technologies
Outlook calendar Maps all of these
things you those help us coordinate our
behavior to be at the same place at the
same time you know cool stuff together
cooperation technologies Google Docs and
you know when we can jump into document
together and come up with a note line
like this for what should we talk about
a webcasting yeah okay and anything
where people can actually begin to work
together okay and then full-on
collaborative mutually beneficial those
are things like uber where hey we're
over the threshold
we're actually generating economic
activity it enables trade and it enables
the transformation of our group
differences that would otherwise cause
problems into a sustainable mutually
beneficial trade relationship asset that
we now are less likely to break Donald
Trump aside I won't even go to market
politics
whoa okay so we will do an like 102
class 102 on peace innovation and peace
technology where we can also have some
of these graphics and breakdowns as well
how about peace design have we been
talking about that we have been yeah and
we've been talking about it a little bit
from the unintentional side you know
nobody at uber said hey let's design a
peace tech company at Airbnb Joe Gebbia
did have the intuition early on this
might be to peace technology you know
and
maybe this could measurably increase
peace in the world and he was right but
the good news here is any company now
that is using any of these technologies
in their daily operations you can
measure how much positive engagement did
we increase between the marketing
department on the engineering department
today in our email you can measure how
much positive engagement did we increase
today between men and women on the
planet in our company today and the the
first the piece the head piece data
standard version 0.1 beta that paper
that Rosana and I and colleague from
Australia
Laurie black memories last name anyway
the three of us published more than a
year ago now we use Bank data looking at
gender engagement in this big Bank
between men and women on the chat
platform so that that company could say
look actually our metadata from our chat
platform shows that in our organization
we're creating this many positive
episodes of engagement between men and
women at this level of quality etc etc
you can go into a great deal of depth
there and an organization can at least
benchmark and say okay we're at least
this good today can we get better and
now when Deloitte comes in and says you
know we've got a intervention to sell
you to increase gender engagement they
can say great let's test it and let's
test it against the one from McKinsey or
whoever else and see which one actually
does so we can create these digital twin
simulations of piece tech yes
Laurie luckily was our other co-authors
Laurie Lockley yeah that was I was gonna
mention this to Dunbar
you've met Nicole and Victoria and
margarita and the whole team you know
I'm a tiny part of a composite person
here in know my name that I'm kind of a
face of but there are a lot of the
brains behind yes yes the team so so we
can do things like create like a digital
twin simulation of what an
organization's internal structure is of
relationships and then we can deploy
pease tech into that simulation see how
it effects sits in a day and then maybe
try that in the physical world and yeah
and a big part of what we do with
organizations is say we can teach you
how to do this yourself internally so
that you can design your own
interventions yeah with each other for
each other by each other in inside your
organization as well as easily pulling
in best practices from others that's
great what would one of those look like
oh all sorts of custom things that they
come up with for themselves now I get
under NDA with some of our industry
partners and yeah we can skip and then
we can always well there's this it as
they can as they can come up to the
surface essentially we've got a process
and here's here's where I think we get
into the ethical deployment of these
things for us to drop in and say hi
we're from Stanford we have a great
solution for you here you know buy and
deploy our piece tech would be
disastrous that's why you come in
potentially and learn ask them questions
learn about them and say have you
considered something like this what
would that look like for you yeah and we
have a very systematic process to come
in and say let us teach you how to
design this stuff for each other
virtually because the only expertise we
really have is teaching people how to
build and design this stuff and how to
ethically deploy it that turns out to be
far more ethical as well I love it and
for us getting more piece stuck out in
the world it it gets many more
practitioners building this stuff and
that's the the Haigh piece data standard
is the ability to go and help these
companies
first of all measure their piece
footprint and eventually start getting
recognition for it and then last but
definitely not least eventually start
getting paid for it because oh damn cool
they're building that relational
infrastructure you know and I guess this
is sort of the last surprising finding
from our research is oh I'm sure the
bottom line increases then oh absolutely
but it massively improved organizational
performance improves your ability to
attract talent improve the retention on
that talent creates a much better
working environment relationships
between that
and so you see organizational
improvement as a result yeah and whoa
yeah whoa yeah that's so cool okay and
then let's give the old example there's
a piece entrepreneurship what what were
the old companies doing you gave the new
company examples yes so I mean piece
entrepreneurship would be somebody today
like Joe Gebbia decade ago saying hey I
actually want to build technology that
does measurably increase peace in the
world and we work with an incubate those
folks some working directly with the
library at Stanford some work with our
city labs around the world and so on the
the big AHA here though is now that we
can measure piece behavior like this the
surprise is where it's happening because
most of it is happening in the work
place the the place where most of us
spend most of our time interacting with
people really different from us is eight
hours a day five days a week at the
office interesting and the place where
most of us are willing to go back and
try again even if it kind of sucked
today is at the office because we're
getting paid for it yeah and it turns
out far more episodes of interaction
between people who are very different
for happen at the workplace are
happening in the workplace yeah there's
a high concentration of people in
diversity or Society back home you're
just with your family members a couple
of inferences so the workplace is where
we're all getting our exec ed on how to
get along with people buddy that's where
we're getting our education yeah yeah
how to get along with people I'm not
interesting nobody thinks it's a moral
problem it's of school too when we're in
some of that early days is hopefully
what allows you to function function in
the workplace yeah yeah okay but um but
yeah nobody is thinking Oh where's
where's the most peace happening in the
world
oh it's happening in the office but it
is you know once you can measure it you
start realizing actually yeah that is
where it's happening yeah
and so that's why we yeah it's a whole
new view on relationships between people
and the piece data that's actually
coming from that that's invisible so
there was to build these metropolis to
build all of the
things that were so grateful for
shelters food water electricity internet
all these things that that there were so
many peace relationships that's it means
PCs and was that and it's easy to look
back in history and see the conflict
because most of history is just a record
of the conflicts and the the all the
cooperation is largely invisible all the
people rewired to notice a look at the
command lists and the violence's oh
there's a big plundering happening of
course that's a problem but at the same
time it's like whatever the multi
hundred years later we're not thinking
about the thousands of people that had
to work together to move those resources
construct that design and make it until
undo all the damage that came from that
one episode of big thundering and then
and then so most of the pieces happening
in the work force which is wow wow right
now companies are not getting any
recognition for that and so that
progression of first of all start
measuring it there that will give us a
big sample of most human pro-social
activity right there second of all start
giving recognition to organizations for
the amount of piece they're creating
because that's building that social
relational infrastructure than that
social fabric that's where we're
actually building social fabric and then
third of all change market signals
because that stuff is really valuable so
let's get them paid for that and then
that makes it investable so that those
big pools of capital in capital markets
you know the pension fund that is has to
pay for your pension the insurance fund
that has to pay your life insurance and
your health insurance they can put that
money into more of this stuff that
builds that relational infrastructure as
opposed to going crap the only thing
that I'm actually allowed to invest in
that gets the returns I have to invest
in is something that is building
Christmases or whatever you know yeah
that's the deep structural problem
that's a whole other episode going to ok
and just I'm gonna quit on the quick on
peace finance and peace investments yeah
that kind of led us a little that's
exactly where we're going here is is by
meant by creating not just a and oh hey
you should get recognition and you're
you as an individual and your team and
your department and your company and
your industry should all be getting
recognition for this stuff because now
we can measure it it isn't just that
it's beyond recognition you should be
getting paid for this so it's about
creating a price signal for the value of
peace in order to make it invest able a
price signal for the value of peace to
make an investable okay so that we can
divert capital flows away from those
things that right now are let me just
give an example I think was more than
ten years ago now the Gates Foundation
was investing in anti malarial stuff in
West Africa if I recall correctly and if
I get the details of this wrong sorry
Bill and Melinda but roughly it's like
this and they were you know it's a
foundation so they have all this
principle that they invest in capital
markets and they earn a return and then
they take a little bit of that return
and give it in grants every year and
they were giving the grants to try and
mitigate malaria spread in West Africa
and their principal was invested in oil
companies that were causing a bunch of
chaos in West Africa that was making the
the interventions they were doing with
their interest really impossible to
deploy in West Africa are really
difficult to deploy and so and it's just
a it's a it's a really basic calculation
about how much capital you have at work
when you've got this much capital at
work drilling for oil in the Niger River
Delta and this much capital the interest
on it available some portion of that
some tiny portion of that available to
try and reduce the spread of malaria
there and it's really hard to get people
in there because there's a civil war
being fought right there because people
are drilling for oil and people are
fighting over the oil it's you just look
at the budgets and go this amount will
always cancel out this amount every time
every time and so what we need is a
systematic way to divert at a bunch of
this into these sectors that are
structured as for profits instead of
NGOs as instead of foundations instead
of philanthropy instead of charity
because philanthropy and charity is not
where peace is happening it might be
where some violence reduction is
happening
but it's not where peace is happening
it's the for-profit workplace where
peace is happening because that's what's
paying the bills yeah for us to all get
that executive education on how to learn
to work together with people who are
different different and by definition
different is up and down your supply
chains up and down your distribution
channels all you got to do is you know
meet your customer and you meet
different real quick yeah and for our
next sit-down we'll touch more on these
subjects and we'll touch on mimetics
genetics conversation as well well I'm
excited I think there's like six
conversations that I want to have with
you now and we barely scratch the
surface the first one but good I'm glad
I'm glad there's I think there's a good
amount of these games of what we call
tennis to play still and to unpack more
of these good wisdoms quick on the way
out we ask our guests if they think that
there are did you come into this earth
suit to play on this planet from
somewhere beyond this physical world
I don't know it seems very unlikely to
me that we are the most supreme beings
around it also seems very unlikely to me
that whatever supreme beings there are
particularly resemble the things that
different religions call God mm-hmm not
it seems highly unlikely to me I think
the kind of organisms the kind of super
organisms that I'm really interested in
are the kinds of which we are to them as
one of my skin cells as to me those are
the super organisms yet I'm interested
in as above so below yeah yeah and I'm
interested in playing my role really
well in that super organism so it can be
a little bit better as a result of me
being one of the cells in it you're
going one more level macro up the view
of the billion of us at play on the
planet we can be a good cell in the
equation exactly yeah and I strongly
suspect that those kind of super
organisms exist and I think they're all
around us
we just don't we haven't learned
biologically and ecologically how to
notice them yet but I you know I think
the city of San Francisco like every
other city on the planet is a living
organism in which yeah you and I are you
know we three ourselves yeah and we come
and go just like you know different
pieces of our organisms come and go
every day and that's that's part of what
I mean when I say we're all food yeah
ready cut Roger called bread by Oh
crumbs by overhead by Oh crud we're food
for something else you know baby all of
us who live in a city one of the reasons
we live there is that to some degree
biologically that city ate us is eating
us it's also feeding us you know and so
in this sense everything is food and we
shouldn't think we're an exception
and that's not a bad thing and then are
we in a simulation that when I got no
idea on it seems very likely to me but
you know I'm not I've read Nick
Bostrom's work I've read some of the
other team out of Berkeley stay I Center
and so on it seems perfectly possible
but I don't have enough data either way
to say one way and then what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
ma'am for me it's transcendence for me
the experience at all sorts of different
points in my life of being part of
something bigger than myself
and and feeling so privileged and so
gratitude so grateful to so full of
gratitude just to be here to be able to
have those experiences you know so the
thing that I've been looking myself in
the mirror the question I've been asking
myself since before I met Tim Brown and
learned that questions are the really
important thing but even as a kid I used
to look in the mirror and ask myself how
can I create the most good in the world
for the greatest number of people as far
into the future as possible and that's
been kind of a mantra for me I've
expanded that now to I'm interested in
all living things not just not just
humans and I suspect that the boundary
between us and other living things is
much more artificial than we would like
to think yeah yeah that's right
as somebody who has I got ill when I was
in Haiti 20 years ago with a bunch of GI
tract problems and you suddenly start
being really aware of your gi flora and
fauna and the trouble and the problems
that can cause when it's not working and
the amazing benefits that work really
well when it is working so you don't
notice it yeah but when you pay
attention to it you realize most of the
stuff that is working for me in here
that is helping me live literally day by
day is not me hmm doesn't have my DNA
doesn't have it's not me at all no
there's this nice partnership going on
here and when that partnership gets
disrupted my health goes to to hell you
know so and then you start realizing
what well then where's the boundary
between me and not me because yeah
there's a bunch of not me here yeah that
I can't survive without so
it's pretty fundamentally me actually
it's just different DNA so yeah yeah
[ __ ] I love that transcendence I love
that Wow
Oh such a good episode cool into one of
my faves has been super fun be my great
pleasure I think my great pleasure I'm
looking forward to coming back thank you
thank you for all the great work we look
forward to a long beautiful partnership
with these innovation I know we need
your help figuring out how to
communicate this stuff better how to get
these ideas out in the world better how
to make it more engaging for folks I
hope this was interesting for your
audience yeah so we're super on it with
you love it love it thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking check out the
links in the bio peace innovation at
stanford.edu also peace innovation calm
go and talk more about this with your
friends your families Congress people
online on social media get talking more
about peace innovation peace technology
visualizing this peace data all the
things that we talked about today and
support the incredible organizations
that you believe in like the peace
Innovation Lab support cool
organizations like simulation so we can
keep doing our thing as well you can
find our links in the bio below to our
patreon paypal cryptocurrency or design
cool merch and get paid links down there
as well
shout out to round Boggess for producing
and directing thank you very much Ron
you're on and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]